hello everyone welcome to another
interesting video by simply learn what
is one of the most important and core
concept of statistics that enable us to
do predictive modeling and yet it is
often confused by aspiring data
scientists yes i am talking about the
central limit theorem so in this video
we will discuss all there is to know
about the central limit theorem so let's
start by discussing the agenda for today
we'll start with the definition of
central limit theorem and then discuss
the mean and standard deviation
associated with it then we'll take a
real life example to understand where
you can use the central limit theorem
then we will discuss some assumptions
that are taken for effective use of
central limit theorem we'll end this
tutorial with a demonstration of the
central limit theorem in python so
without further ado let's get started so
what is the central limit theorem the
central limit theorem is a statistical
concept that states that the sample
means of the distribution of a random
variable will approach to a normal
distribution if the sample sizes are
large respective of the shape of the
original population distribution we take
the population and we take the samples
out of them let's discuss the mean and
standard deviation associated with it
suppose we are sampling from a
population with mean mu and a standard
deviation sigma let x be the random
variable representing the sample mean of
n independently drawn observations then
we can say that the mean of the sampling
distribution of the sample means is
equal to the population mean which is mu
x bar is equal to mu where mu x by
represents the mean of the sample means
mu represents the population mean on
other hand the standard deviation of the
sampling distribution will be equal to
the population of the total standard
deviation upon the under root of sample
size
let's understand this more clearly by
taking a real world example suppose you
are a digital manager pharmaceutical
company in charge of 200 stores across
the region and you are in charge of
weekly medicine restocking at all of
them you need to know how many cases to
order weekly for each store in order to
reduce the amount of inventory that
expires the plot on the right-hand side
shows the distribution of all the 200
stores and average medicine cases
required by each of the stores in the
week
the red line represents the average
cases required which is equal to 24. you
know there has to be a better way to
arrive at a reasonable answer that
doesn't entail visiting every single
store in your area and obtaining their
weekly sales figure you can apply the
central limit theorem to this problem
not until you understand the concept we
already know the central limit theorem
when applied to real problems aids in
balancing the time and cost of gathering
the data required to draw the
conclusions about the data so here you
can see the plot on the right hand side
shows the distribution of sample means
of the sufficiently large subsets taken
from the population sample size greater
than 30 will be sufficient enough to get
the normal bell curve the mean of all
the samples taken from that population
mean is equal to 34 which is equal to
the sample mean of the subsets if you
plot the sample means you will get a
normal distribution which is a form for
bell curve if these samples meet the
central limit theorem category you can
assume the distribution of the sample
means can be approximated to the normal
distribution now you know how to apply
the central limit theorem in a real
world problem let's discuss some
assumptions behind the central limit
theorem the first one is the
randomization condition the data must be
sampled at randomly and it must adhere
to the randomization rule the second one
is the independence assumption the
sample value must be independent of each
other this means that the occurrence of
one event has no influence on the next
event usually if we know that people or
items were selected randomly we can
assume that the independent assumption
is met the third and the last one is the
10 condition this states that when the
sample is drawn without replacement the
sample size which is n should be no more
than the 10 percent of the population
let's now discuss some application of
the central limit theorem political and
election polling is a great example to
show how you can use the central limit
theorem these post results are used to
estimate the number of people who
support a specific candidate to
calculate the confidence interval which
is shown on the news channel the central
level theorem is very useful in this one
more place where you can use a central
limit theorem is a census data you use
the central limit theorem to calculate
the various population details such as
family income electricity consumption
individual salaries and so on now that
we have a good understanding of the
central limit theorem theories and
application let's see a demo in python
to understand it more clearly here we
are on an online compiler we'll discuss
the clt by taking a nice example a dice
is a different number on each side
ranging from 1 to 6. each number has a
one in six chances of appearing on a
roll given all the equal likelihood the
dispersion of the numbers that come up
from a dice role is uniform let's start
by importing some necessary libraries
we'll import the numpy first
from numpy dot random will import the
random function which will be used to
generate the random integers
we'll also import the mean function from
the numpy we'll set the seed to 1. now
we'll write the function to generate a
random numbers
the randid function will generate a
number ranging from 1 to 6. we have
taken the 100 because the example will
generate the print the samples of 100
dice rows along with the mean print the
rows
and then we'll print the mean of the
rules so when you run this code we will
get the following result you see we have
the hundred numbers and the mean of this
number is 3.38 now we'll repeat the
process thousand times this will give
you the result of thousand sample means
according to the clt the result of the
sample means will be gaussian
so
we'll change this code from here means
will be equal to
mean of
this
random integers we'll take from 1 comma
7 comma 100 and this will be 4
in range of
1000
now we'll plot this distribution we'll
use the pi plot function we'll get the
graph as a histogram graph so we'll plot
it in that
means
and pi plot dot show
let's recheck our code we have the
random clear function we have the seed
okay we have imported the mean
we have not imported the math plot
library so from
plot library
will import pipeline now i think
everything is in place and let's try to
run this code
yep you can see this graph is a
histogram graph in a shape of a bell
curve
and if you see closely the mean is
closely to 3.4
so that's it for this tutorial thank you
for being here and watch out for more
videos from us if you have any doubts
and queries regarding the central limit
theorem you can post that in the comment
section until then keep learning and
stay tuned to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here